[Musik]
und jetzt sind wir sehr glücklich und haben eine sehr,
sehr mächtige, sehr, sehr starke NATO, die viel
stärker ist als vor zwei Tagen. Als
wir gingen, kamen alle in diesem Raum
zurecht und stimmten zu, mehr zu zahlen
, und sie stimmten zu, zu zahlen  es geht schneller
nein das machen andere Leute
ich nicht ich bin sehr konsequent ich bin ein sehr
stabiles Genie
[Musik]
ich habe den Premierminister nicht kritisiert ich
habe großen Respekt vor dem
Premierminister und leider da  war eine
Geschichte, die gemacht wurde, die im
Allgemeinen gut war, aber sie enthielt nicht das, was
ich jetzt über die Premierminister-Geschichten gesagt habe,
also haben wir sie zu Ihrem Vergnügen, wenn
Sie möchten, aber wir zeichnen auf, wenn wir
mit Reportern zu tun haben  nennt sich Fake News und
wir lösen viele Probleme.
Ich denke, es ist eine schreckliche Sache, die
Deutschland tut. Ich denke, es ist ein schrecklicher
Fehler, und so sehr ich Angela mag, war
ich sehr offen und habe es gesagt. Ich denke, es ist
eine schreckliche Sache, dass Sie eine
Pipeline haben  komme aus Russland und ich
glaube, Deutschland ist g
50 60 oder sogar ich habe gehört, dass
70 % ihrer Energie aus
Russland kommt Ich denke, wir haben viele Telefone Ich
denke, die Europäische Union ist ein Feind
Ich denke nicht an die Europäische Union, aber sie sind
ein Feind. Russland ist in gewisser Hinsicht
ein Feind. China ist ein ökonomischer Feind. Sicherlich sind
sie ein Feind
Unsere Konkurrenten
wollen es gut machen und wir wollen es gut machen und
[Musik]
das, aber ich denke, wir werden am Ende
eine außergewöhnliche Beziehung haben, das
habe ich gesagt und ich bin mir sicher, dass Sie es
über die Jahre und so gehört haben  Ich kämpfe dafür, dass
das Zusammenleben mit Russland eine gute
Sache ist, keine schlechte Sache, oder
effizient, indem
ich die Position
bejahe  Autismus, unser größter
Baba macht heiße Schwester in dieser Sit  e bei
fieldstone kann man sie einfach lieben